if you don't mind let's ask one question
till later
and erupted open to togethertown
and start our grand finale of two days
uh which is uh the talk by
uh shy ben david
about uh as you could see if peavers and
p
uh can be independent of the axioms of
reasoning
and uh suggest couple of force to
introduce
uh tribe david his work spans
a really vast range from uh
kind of from said theory of
kind of really uh deep state theory
that really practical machine learning
uh with algorithm and complexity and
logic
and all sorts of things in between
and shy can
connect all those different things and
shows the relations
where uh you know it's hard to imagine
that there could
even be relations for example um
independent result of a machine learning
problem
uh this is one of your newest best paper
awards right
no no this is that one not this one okay
so you have other papers
which you got new looks um best paper
awards and such
anyway so surprise word funds
food area and it's really beautiful and
today he's going to tell us about
that really cool result about sad and
fever simply and independence please
okay so i'll try to be and not technical
i know what we're running
behind time so yeah so i i want to look
at this question of whether
p versus np can be independent of set
theory and here
i mean as in contrast to to what sasha
was saying
when you look at negative results the
stronger the
system you can show that cannot prove
something the more
the stronger the result is so i'm
talking i'm really
interested in much stronger systems i'm
not
going to talk about sat or anything how
to solve that
but uh so what was the talk about so
when you're faced with some hard
mathematical problem there's always the
temptation to think that maybe
this problem is inherently irresolvable
maybe the reason that we fail to find
answers is not
our lack of wisdom but rather than no
answer no proof
exists i mean that's following gather we
know that this is always a possibility
when we're facing an open problem so the
the goal of this research was
to see uh try to ask why do we fail to
resolve some basic computational
complexity questions
could it be that p versus np or other
componential
open problems are unresolvable
in set theory which means we have no
tools of proving
that the answer and
more concretely is it likely that right
that
the tools that we have in mathematics
are inherently too weak
to determine relationship between
complexity classes
and so i mean if we believe in such a
direction then
we should direct our efforts to
answering these
logical reality questions rather than
struggle with
directly computational complexity issues
because maybe
it's hopeless maybe by showing that i
mean
that's you know the the kind of the line
of research that sasha was taking and
and others in in this community that
don't try this direction because it's
it's a
brutal so um
what do we know about independence move
just to remind
everybody about independence proof of
set theory so
uh gilbert's program was to the hope to
develop a former method that will
resolve all mathematical questions
and of course get those incomplete
results show that this plan
is bound to fail every reasonable
mathematical framework
has irresolvable question and we will
call
a problem independent of a theory t if
we cannot
t cannot prove and neither the
statement s no its negation and gathers
show that
the consistency of it here it is always
such an independent statement with
respect to t
but of course what we are interested in
is other
relevant real mathematical questions
that fall in this category of
being unresolvable
by said theory which means unresolvable
by what we
call mathematical proof okay so what do
we know about that
uh so what what is the the
set theory that we look at so
a formal theory that defines kind of
commonly defined what mathematical proof
is about is the set theory
that you see there is a slightly weaker
theory which
talks about arithmetic arithmetic we all
know it and
just to mention that planar arithmetic
is equivalent
to set theory uh if we just delete
the statement of existing infinite set
so
and since says the lipstick can prove
the consistency of parent arithmetic we
can
build in zfcm model for a number theory
then we know that it's strictly stronger
than apa
even with respect to statements about
natural numbers because the statement
panel arithmetic is consistent
is can be phrased as a statement above
natural numbers so here is a statement
about natural numbers that
you can prove that we said we said if
see with the assumption with the
extra axiom there exists an infinite set
and you cannot prove this statement
in panoramic although it is a phanatary
statement about natural numbers okay so
that's kind of the background
and the paul cohen showed that there are
really questions that are
independent of that theory and the
continuum authorities
and and is a kind of a sounding
example of this and uh since then there
have been many many independent
results in set theory it started with
cardinal arithmetic and infinite
combinatorics
group theory topology function analysis
algebra and recently we had as
antonina mentioned we had an
independence results
of set theory in for very very basic
question machine learning
so con what can we say about
independence results for computational
complexity do all of this
kind of say machinery of being able to
show that things are independent of
a strong theory does it apply
to a complexity combination complexity
statements
so the uh there is an
old result of hopelessness monies
that says that for any tre t we can find
a turing machine
such as as an the oracle complexity
uh with respect to this turing machine
cannot be uh decided
uh in in t this is kind of a
diagonalization
trick and talks about the
oracle p versus np with respect to some
specially crafted orc so
that was kind of the first result and
then there were
several results of independence of
weaker fragments of uh
arithmetic we also were already
mentioned here some
uh there are some first there were
artificial fragments that will come
meant to be weak enough
so that you will not be able to prove
much with those weak fragments
then there was a bounded arithmetic
it depends uh like they're famous in the
tremendous results of
sasha and all kind of
limiting the proof techniques so it
relativized their proofs that was the
the oracle result of baker gil and
solovey
and then if you limit the proofs in a
in other words exactly what sasha was
talking about
then there are statements you will not
be able to prove and
then later there's the algebraic proofs
of
uh wingers uh but
uh can we prove the independence of p
versus np from set theory could this be
the case
so there are inherent limitations
that the point is that to realize that
since paul coin in 1960
volcano introduced the technique of
forcing
and in some sense we do not have
any new techniques for showing the
dependence of set theory in
in a high level they all follow the same
pattern i will not get into describing
this pattern but
important to notice about it that all
the
proof techniques that we have for
showing independence from set theory
they cannot show independence of any
statements
that involves only natural numbers only
finite sets
so we do not have any technique that has
a hope of showing
independence of statement like p versus
np
because those are finitary statements
existed during machines such that
and there exists a k such that for all
formulas and so on
everything is planetary all the tools
that we have for showing independence
from
full set theory uh can be
shown and not to be able to show such
independence
so we have to go to uh
that's what i'm trying to explain why
it's a planetary statement it's for
every code p there is a chewing machine
and a k and and so on we know we know
that
p versus n p can be written as a fallacy
statement
in in in the language of say a number
theory
so what can we hope to prove so i'm
saying we cannot
we don't have any tools that would be
able to show independence of p versus np
of
full set theory but what about
non-profitability from parana arithmetic
that's kind of the next
best thing that we could hope for
so um this is
a weaker theory and a weaker theory it
would be easier to show
a statement that it fails to prove
naturally and it will be
a very interesting result because
independence with respect to pan or
arithmetic
would be quite satisfactory it will tell
you that
without assuming without using
a statement there exist infinite sets
we will not be able to resolve our
complexity
uh questions so showing independence of
pan arithmetic i think would be a
kind of could could be something to hope
for as a mathematician
because it really tells you that we
cannot resolve
uh p versus np i mean the the
possibility that for having to resolve
it we have to assume
the existence of infinite sets or even
stronger
infinite cardinals does not uh
we have no way of incorporating or even
imagining how it could be relevant so
this could be an
interesting goal so i can go back to my
first slide what i'm saying is
rather than trying to solve p versus np
maybe what we should do is try to show
that it is independent of parental
arithmetic
if it's independent and parallel
arithmetic in some sense
our efforts to show it uh to prove it
about
to fail okay so
uh do we know of any independence from
pan arithmetic
or free mathematical statements so as i
mentioned before we do have
results about independence from uh
zfc and of course they are independent
from piano arithmetic
but these are all about statements which
involve
infinite sets so do we have any uh
statements about in the independence
from
planar arithmetic of real mathematical
statements of course
the consistency of parent arithmetic is
independent of parent arithmetic but we
want to talk about
inherently mathematical statements so
the first such result was paris and
harrington and that was a
very a big breakthrough at the time they
talk
uh they took a natural version of
ramsey theorem that we can prove instead
of c
that this is a true theorem it's just
the usual website theorem but just
i mean i have not repeated but just
mentioned to those that are familiar
with randy
that the only addition here is that the
homogeneous
said that the existence of this set uh
is guaranteed by ramsey tom should be
larger
than the first natural number in this
city
which seems like a small minor addition
to ramses theorem
and it really indeed provable that it's
true but
they showed you cannot prove it internal
arithmetic
so that was kind of giving hope that
there are
mathematical statements about
finite sets that are independent of
parent arithmetic
although they're approvable in the fc
the question we are aiming for
is to ask is it likely to be the case
for p
versus and p or other complexity
problems
so uh there are similar results later
uh statements about natural numbers uh
it's fun to redistinct the calculus and
the hijra
i don't know if you heard about this
it's kind of a puzzle
that you have a tree and you you have
leaves from the tree which are heads of
the hijra
and you are hercules and you are having
a sword and you are cutting heads
but each time you're cutting heads it
grows more heads and
it grows on more heads in the scary way
the the formula
and still one can prove that no matter
how
bad as a hercules as alcoholism you are
you will eventually kill the hydra but
this eventually is
very long and to prove such a system so
to prove such a statement
uh we can do it in zfc but we cannot do
it in paranormal
and again it's a financial statement
you're playing a game against a finite
tree which is the hidden
the interesting relevance to us is that
the structure of
a p not equal in p is
syntactically it looks the same as the
paris harrington
because the paris sanctum is a ramsey
theorem it says
for every uh ret and the
size and the number of colors there
exists homogeneous set
of such size and here the
p not equal in p have a very natural a
very similar
uh syntactic structure it says for every
x
there exists a y such that phi x y
which is like the ramsey for every
parameters you have
and size you have a homogeneous set and
the statement
this set is homogeneous end of this site
does not contain
any unbounded quantifiers and it's the
same with speed versus mph as you want
to show
that for every program and every
bound or the polynomial of the runtime
of the program
there exists a
instance of that such that this program
will give you the wrong answer
so the statement is syntactically looks
like the paris serengton
so we we could hope that maybe we could
show a similar result independence of
parent arithmetic
for p naught equal mp okay so that's
what i'm i was set to try to understand
and the conclusion of this work if we
jump
right to the end is that
if on one hand if that can be solved
in almost polynomial time so say p is
not equal in p
but that can be solved in time which is
very very close to being polynomial and
then
elaborate on it later if that can be
solved in
almost polynomial tile then you cannot
prove
that p is not equal in p
and now the concrete notion of almost
polynomial depends on the theory in
which you want to prove it so for every
theory
there is a notion of close to
polynomial such that if np
if sat can be solved in such close to
polynomial time
then that theory will not be able to
prove
the separation between p and p because
the sat has a solution that looks almost
like polynomial
and the theory the the almost will be so
fine
that the toa will not be able to
distinguish between the two
so that's not so not so much of a
surprising result but it's something
that's worthwhile to bear in mind and
i'll
get back to it a bit later but the
surprise here
is that we also can show the other
direction
so if the theory is sufficiently strong
then the reverse statement also holds
namely
the only possible reason for failure of
the theory to prove that p is not equal
in p
is that sat can be solved by an
algorithm which is
almost polynomial time so
in some sense it says loosely stated
that if you can prove that a strong
mathematical theory cannot show
that p is not equal in p you will imply
that sat has a solution which is almost
polynomial time
so solving the logical statement the
higher level logical statement
p versus independent of set theory
will be as hard as coming up
with a polynomial almost normal time for
so in some sense that let's say the main
conclusion of this
of this talk that
there's no point of in you don't get
much advantage by struggling with logic
and trying to show
that p versus mp is independent of set
theory because
this will be as hard as showing that you
have a polynomial
uh algorithm almost
okay so that's at this point i i said
the most important things of the talk
and now i want to go a little bit into
the technical details and and kind of uh
convey the intuition which is not so
complex at all
of why this is indeed the case
so we would consider
what do we mean by almost polynomial i'm
talking now about
sats has a solution which is almost
polynomial time
so what do we mean by almost polynomial
so we look at running time which is n to
the fn
where the exponent f n grows very very
slowly
so it means that the running time has a
constant
exponent for huge stretches of input
length
so the function f n i want it to grow
very very slowly the exponential the
exponent of n
of the runtime and if the function goes
very
slowly we can view it as the inverse of
a fast growing function
so we will it will be in some sense it's
easier to talk about how fast
a function grows rather than talking
about
how slow it does so i'll
we'll talk about the inverse of the
function which
is the exponent of the runtime
so what here are some fast-growing
functions the
wayne a hierarchy so this is a way of
constructing very fast growing functions
so f1 of n is 2n
and now for every uh ordinal
countable ordinal lambda f
lambda plus one of n is just you apply f
of f of f you compose n time f lambda
and apply to n
and if you take a limit ordinal
then you also have to define for a limit
ordinary for a limit ordinal
you just at the end step you apply you
take a sequence
delta n that converges to
delta to your limit ordinal and that
ends
for to compute f of n you apply
the function composed
the delta of n times so
this is a very a way of defining a very
fast growing functions the argument
function is just
f omega is the first
infinite ordinal in this sequence it's
only the optimal function
but then as we see here we can keep
going we can
applying it further and further and
further and get faster and faster
growing
function that's the kind of the
functions that
we will talk about whose inverses will
be
the exponents of the one time
if indeed you could prove independence
of p versus and p
so just to demonstrate here i know i
mean this is a sophisticated audience i
don't have to convince you
but like f f 2
of 3 is already a crazy
number somehow something hides it for me
but anyway anybody can do this
calculations
it's crazy first even f3
f omega is aquaman's function and we go
beyond it
okay now how far beyond that we grow
when we want our functions to grow very
very very fast
so uh it's common to denote by epsilon
zero the first ordinal
such that omega to the power alpha
equals alpha with
the powers here are ordinal powers but
and i i will not get into the definition
but this is the limit of
omega omega to the power omega m power
omega 2 omega
and we take the countable
limit this so
this is epsilon zero and
we will be interested in the function f
epsilon zero so we take this when a
hierarchy
and we push it and push it and push it
we go through
the acumen function is just here at f
omega and then we keep going and going
and going and going and we get to this
a stationary point a fixed point
of this function and we take this
crazily growing function why do we care
about this function
so we care about such a function because
it has i mean
the next step is the way i connect
fast-growing functions and complexity
conjectures i mean this is
fun to talk about fast-forwarding
functions and hidden and so on
but it does relate to computational
complexity
so how do we make the connection
so given a
a complexity class which has
which you can enumerate as a countable
set of algorithms as some canonical
enumeration of the class
i guess this is what pablo was calling a
syntactic class and given a language
i can define a function and the function
it measures how well can this
class approximate the language l
so this function at the point i
it is the maximum of so i go
over m1 m2 m3 and so on up to mi
and i see which of them can compute
l correctly on longer initial segments
so again i go over all functions in
here is my class m one and two and so on
i'm going up at point i
i'm going over all the i first i
machines
or first i programs and then
for each of them i look at the minimum
point where it fails to compute my
language
l and i take the maximum
so this tells me how many machines do i
have to consider
in order to correctly compute the
language
l on the first uh
i
how far can any of the first
machines can compute my language this is
what we are doing here
so we define a function that
measures how well can a class of
functions
approximate a given language and it is
easy to realize that this function is
total
if and only if l is not
in the class because if l is in the
class
there will be some i such that there
will never be a failure
this machine mi will compute the class
correctly and we are just looking at the
first time
that all the first i machines fail
so this is a total function for every i
there is
a number out of i if and only if the
function
is not in the class and furthermore
the faster this function grows the
closer
is l to the class because it means that
fewer machines right f i tells me
how far could any of the first i
machines
compute l correctly so if it grows fast
it means that i need few machines
to compute big stretches l on big
stretches of x's so
um the faster this function
goes the closer is the class the
function
the language l to the class c so
here we kind of measure how
far it's not just p not equal in p but
i'm trying to measure how far
is sat from the class of polynomial time
functions so it gives a quantitative
measure and this is the function that
will
apply our knowledge about our
discussion of fast-growing functions so
we enumerate all p-time machines
and the we assume that we have
some kind of easy mapping computable
mapping from index i to the code of the
ice machine
and we can without loss of generality
assume that the ice machine
is bounded by n to the log i i mean
they're all
just enumerating for normal time
machines and then we can get
this nice connection between this
function out
and the computational complexity of
computing sat
so if r is this approximation
function of sat by a p
then sat is in deterministic time
um d to the log g of
n for every function g that bounds
r minus one so now let's stop and see
what it means
r is how easy i can how far
i can approximate a sat
r is a function that if sat that grows
very fast
so r minus 1 is a very slow growing
function
and i so g is just a computable function
that
up about r minus one and it means that
if sat
can be approximated well by
this procedure by enumerating all
polynomial machines
then sat is in deterministic time
which this is a very close to constant
very slow growing function
because almond r is fast growing r minus
one is very slow growing i take the log
of it
and so i have this in the exponent the
exponent is almost a constant
so we're using fast growing functions
we're looking at the inverses
as a way of measuring how close that is
to p
and the quality is that the
approximation
rate of p by
sat gives us a notion of
almost polynomial time algorithm so if
the approximation rate is fast
is a fast growing function then sat is
really almost polynomial
the exponent is almost a constant
okay so at this point we have the
ingredients for our reasoning
we have the notion of fast-growing
function in the relation to sat
and the class p but of course what we
want to do is relate it to
a probability so what's the connection
between this and
and probability or in particular to the
probability
of p versus np so
a function is called probably recursive
i guess you all know it if you can
prove in your theory that
it holds they have an algorithm that
computes this function
and holds on every input and the
probably recursive functions respect to
pa
and pa1 i haven't yet defined p1 and
defined in a second
it's the pi one closure of pa
is the same so we can talk about being
proven recursive without making this
distinction
and uh there is the wayner theorem and
the way that when i was the
is from this hierarchy and the function
is every f
alpha for alpha less than epsilon zero
is probably
recursive and this is if in some sense
it's if and only if
if a function is supposedly recursive
then
it is dominated by some f alto
so this divine hierarchy what it gives
us
is a way to determine
how fast can a function grow and still
be provably recursive still we could
prove that for every x
there is f of x and the answer is that
roughly
the bound is this f epsilon 0
in the minor hierarchy so
the corollary is that if a function
grows very fast
it's not dominated by any of those
functions
then piano arithmetic and its closure
by pi one functions by parallel
statements
cannot prove that the function is total
i guess i don't have time to explain the
the result it's a classical result it's
a beautiful result but
if a function grows too fast you cannot
prove that this function is total
uh and um the parasiton actually the
proof
that a piano arithmetic cannot resolve
this
ramsey type trm is that is exactly by
showing that
the ramsey number that you take
parameters and you want to
ask how fast should your graph be in
order to get such homogeneous set
it's such a fast-growing function that
it's beyond the scope
of what panel arithmetic can prove it is
complete and in parallel it
cannot prove that it's complete it
cannot prove that
for every input parameters there
is indeed a large enough graph that will
give you a homogeneous set for these
parameters
so this is exactly the the tool the
machinery behind the paris ericton
independence result
and
most of the proofs of independent from
prior arithmetics of statements that
we can prove in zfc instead theory
have this kind of nature they generate a
very fast growing function and show that
this
fast point function is beyond the limit
that is stated by weiner's theorem
so this repeats in other independence
proof
respect to plan arithmetic so what we
can conclude here
that if the approximation rate of sat by
p is very fast-growing function then
parallel arithmetic cannot prove that p
is not equal in p and
so if sat can be solved by an almost
polynomial time algorithm
then para arithmetic will not be able to
prove
that they are different okay so that's
one direction of our theorem
the maybe the more interesting direction
is the other direction
and so
the inverses of fast-growing functions
are functions that are
very very almost constant
their own big stretches they're
constantly i'm trying to rush
because i see the clock we're getting
too close to
a two o'clock here and to the end of
the recording so what i'm saying is that
if a function goes very fast
uh if the this function r
the approximation grows very fast
then there are long stretches on which
sat can be solved in
a fixed polynomial and so the next step
is showing that
this is the only reason for
non-probability of
p versus np and
i show it with respect to the theory pa1
pa1 is i
add to piano arithmetic all the pi 1
true statements
now pa1 so expand arithmetic
plus all the taiwan formulas that are
true in standard
models of arithmetic and what do we know
about this property of p1 it's not a
recursive theory
that's a big negative but
there is some notion some notion of some
sense of representative representation
independence
uh i mean it has the it exactly the
theory that we need
in order to be able to show that if you
have two turing machine to prove that
two turing machines can compute
the same function are indeed
computing the same function so in order
to show representation independence of
turing machines
we need the theory pa1 and
so it's in some sense it's a natural
theory to consider when we want to talk
about
uh independence of run time and turing
machines
and we can also
the nice properties if p equals and p
then p and y and can prove it because
you can have this polynomial time
algorithm and pa1 can prove the
statement
for every input it computes sat
correctly
okay so we switched to the theory pa1
which is much
stronger and now we have the theorem
that
uh p a1 proves p
equals and not equal in p if and only if
the approximation rate of p is
low or in other way in other
words so i mean before i
talk about the proof idea what we we
care about here is to show that
player 1 will be able to if if sat is
far from p
pa 1 will be able to show it and
the only reason that it cannot show it
could be that sat
is very very close to p and the
the proof idea i guess we don't have
much time for proofs now
but we can write this as a taiwan
statement so
the conclusion is that if pa1 fails to
prove
a p naught equal and p then sat has
almost polynomial time algorithms
and uh more on the significance
so i want to show that if pa1
cannot prove that they are different i
mean
then in some in some sense we cannot
distinguish
an independence proof between pa1 and pa
because the generic way in which we show
that the theory
does not prove some statement the the
coin forcing style is to
start with the model we assume that the
theory is consistent so we have a model
m
we construct the sub model in which
you get the opposite of the of the
statement
and such a sub model will also
satisfy the pi 1 theory of the first
model
so what i'm saying any tool that we have
with the hope of showing that something
is independent of piano arithmetic
will also show us independence of pa1
and therefore if we could show
independence of sat
of p versus and p it will mean that sat
is very close to p
so this is the bottom line
so if it is provable that p versus p is
independent of p a then sat
can be solved in deterministic time t to
the g
of n where g is a very very slow growing
function of g minus one
is a very fast growing function which
will mean that
sat is almost in p and that's if and
only if statement
i think i've just we have similar
results for silicon complexity
we can show that for example if
a piano arithmetic cannot show
is if p versus and p is independent of
planar arithmetic
then there are no one-way functions and
all kind of results in this
nature but i am out of time so i will
stop here and
take some questions if you can still
take questions
thank you so much yeah let's
please ask questions and uh sorry for
right now with time but please do ask
questions
if if somebody asks may i ask a really
naive question
i have a question oh yeah you have a
question okay
go ahead okay it does um this
the proof technique also allow you to go
uh
further down in the strength of the
theory for instance
to replace piano arithmetic by i sigma 1
and
m f epsilon naught by akaman
that's an interesting that it it seems
that i mean
it's an interesting direction i haven't
thought about it i haven't thought about
wicked theories
i mean as sasha was saying right at the
start i come from
working on zfc but yeah i think it's a
very interesting
question it's not inconceivable
okay
more questions
for you please please yeah yeah right
so so i understand the the message
uh is that the problem is that we are
not able to distinguish between pa and
pa-1 we are not not really able to
understand what what are the basic
uh things in uh
arithmetic we we know what what is the
induction but
if ghana ethnic was formalized with some
stronger
uh basic theory then uh everything that
we are able to prove about piano
arithmetic
would be the same uh and this is
what what i also i completely agree with
you
but i i would like to add that the
similar thing is
in complexity here that we are not able
to
distinguish uh computations that
uh have uh different basic operations
like uh yeah say if we allow
turing machine and access to oracle and
say
well what the oracle computes is the
elementary operation
so so then uh various things can happen
and this is the
relativizations so so that i think it's
an interesting
question sorry i think it's a very
interesting analogy right
yes okay
actually a question to both of you
because i kept thinking about
the relation between your talk shy and
[ __ ] stock
uh i will talk about uh semantic classes
and the question of complete problems
and you heavily use the fact
that p is a syntactic class right is
that right
so is there any kind of connection
between those
yeah i really don't i mean i i use very
heavily i mean
all of this line of all of this
machinery
is about syntactic classes
right
and thomas is asking you to show the
second last slide again
okay and this one or the before that
uh look at that new thing before that
yeah thanks right
yeah this is about why why we cannot
distinguish pa1 from piero but pavel was
talking about yeah
so do you want me to repeat it or you
want to ask something about it
no thank you oh okay
sorry i have i have very naive question
so
assume that i am telling you that
npe is not a subset of quasipolynomial
time in the real world
right
it means or or maybe i mean something or
you are saying that it implies that p is
not equal to np is likely weaker
statement
is probable in piano artist
is what you're saying yeah
yeah this is a rough way of putting it
right
sounds sounds very strong to me
now it's not provable in piano
arithmetic
one slide further or where you have a
result
here it is it says period
yeah yeah but but here it is the the
here
i have the caveat by any method known
today so what public
public was saying correctly i mean
probably we can show
it will be uh provable in pa1 but there
is no mathematical tool that will
distinguish p1 from pa
so now we have to take a second step on
top of it and saying
by existing tools okay good
okay thank you
[Music]
more question comments to any speakers
to and from any speakers
okay thank you very very much everybody
this is
such a fantastic session sorry for
running over time but
i don't want it to end this is fantastic